thank you
[Music]
it's time for our semi-annual just
kidding news kinky test kinky test we do
a stinky test every year okay
semi-annually we do it multiple times we
must have forgot about that so we're
gonna talk about a particular Kink and
we're going to decide if it's kinky even
if it's something that we like or or
vanilla or perhaps not but we're not
going to Kink Shane okay or my I I might
King Shame a little we probably will but
we're gonna try not to King Street I
think over the years tastes change yes
yeah what if what if being King shamed
is your Kink
then you better stop getting horned
around me
so what do you guys think about age play
[Laughter]
I think we can move on yeah we got this
older someone plays younger so yeah it's
it's a reform of role play where both
Partners pretend to be and get off on
being an age other than their own
and sometimes
people do baby stuff
yeah I like if I was like I'm never
participating I'm 30 now but like it'd
be cool to be 39 you know
so do you think it's it doesn't arouse
you the idea of age play but can you
understand what that someone else would
be around yeah
what do you understand about yeah if
they're you know pedophile adjacent oh
wow that's a joke that's a joke that's a
joke that was a joke leave it at least
zoom in on it I mean [__] mean it
happens in porn
I'm not like a role player so yeah role
players I don't know if I could do that
Colleen he's a 10 right the guys are 10.
but he wants the age play but he's he
needs to go like I want my mommy
I was like really fast
no he's a tent but that's his thing yeah
he's a Hemsworth yeah yeah he's he's all
the hemsworthy
okay the next one's AIDS play do you
like AIDS
you're a ta
right now that my gay uncle died of AIDS
but that's fine I already knew that I
moved on I moved on and it wasn't
because he was gay
he did gay gay play
well my parents told me it was because
he had it was a dirty needle but then
later they told me that so they paid him
as a heroinette
that's worse they said like the hospital
gave him a shot oh does that does that
ruin AIDS play for you or is it I think
it ruined dates but that's so funny how
they they would think your uncle is a
[__] heroin junkie and you were like
oh thank God I thought he would be gay
or something
my parents weren't
really cool about about
hey but when Uncle Bob came he always
gave us gifts and he always had his like
guy friend and I was always like what's
up dude what's up man but I never put it
together dude they're just friends kids
are stupid
okay what do you guys think about
abrasion what's that getting scraped up
sexually aroused from getting scratched
oh I used honestly I used to like that
yeah really when I was in hard scratch
when I was in like 18 19. I asked my ex
to scratch the [__] on my back and then
it was so deep one time that I was like
I don't think I like it no more yeah oh
that's why he's like I like getting my
back stretched when I'm in the
missionary position but that's not too
hard for like Everyone likes getting
their backs yeah it's just nah Asian
sounds like
let's get some sandpapered oh like I was
Bloody on my back and they sold it yeah
they sold at Brookstone it's probably
not like a kinky thing no no back
scratchers I'm pretty boring when it
comes to sex because I don't like
painful things you just see chicks faces
as chairs but your whole life you've
never tried [__] and went too far and
then like switched it up
I never
experience
like pain stuff let me try this one out
I don't really like paint stuff either
it's like Joe's at bookstore I'm trying
all the different things
can I put my feet up on this one
that guy's kinky like oh [__] guys the
the closest thing that I experienced
would be like a hickey where it's like
oh that hurts but it feels so cool
dude I like Joe's naughty voice bro yeah
Joe's naughty boy I experienced that
when I was like 14 or something my first
girlfriend in the movie theater were
making out his [__] and then she went to
my neck and I was like what is this and
I'm like what is that and then I was
like oh my God it hurts but it's so good
I had a chick sucked on my toes one time
and I was like can you stop doing this
that's weird
I don't even know what the [__] was
going on it was really dark and I didn't
see her for a sec and then I was like
what the [__] the [__] yeah girls
shouldn't be sucking on dudes don't
sucking my toes are nasty oh yeah in
general it's just weird yeah I don't get
I don't get it either I don't get it I
don't I don't think I would ever want my
toes to be sucked me neither that's
cause where she parked did it really no
it's so aggressive I've only I've only
had that experience one time and I
returned the favor and I was like you
didn't wash your feet
that's even worse that's so disgusting
whoa it happened to me in a Jacuzzi so
oh that's nice oh yeah it's mostly wet
anyway we'll watch their feed they just
didn't do a good job okay what do you
guys think about acti rasty what's
active arrest I just found out about it
he's not bummed out oh he's acting Rusty
like if you're acting like a Rastafari
no good yes babe I put my dreads off
I'm about to make love to you so good
fetishes that revolve around the weather
there's Toronto philia which is the
sexual arousal from thunderstorms
see see thunderstorms gonna be horny
kind of tight though yeah I think that's
something I mean like rainy days are
like nice
we're stuck inside yeah dude you heard
some thunderstorms oh or just put on
twister yeah twister that's good you get
all the sounds yeah come on now you're
playing with fire watching the flight on
an airplane that's a premature
ejaculation waiting to happen yeah like
it's about to happen he's watching the
same film
um you might you might have heard about
a sexual arousal from snow or
chionophilia
brothers everything I think snow is cool
I like snow I know it's cool sexually
aroused I think that could be if I was
in the mental space What about
the sexual arousal from rays of sunlight
oh yeah okay is that when those hippies
are putting like their [__] into the
sun okay let me say this in their
defense have you ever had your dick
shined on upon by the sun yeah it's kind
of kind of kind of sweet you can't stay
there for too long because it starts
burning it burns no what not forever
yeah
this is my life now
holy dick
I don't know no those things aren't
intense enough I think that stuff is
more
that seems
it's like more of a okay that seems more
of a possibility than the [__] other
stuff is there a kink for someone who
like sucks your dick on accident how
does that happen I don't know I made it
up like they tripped and falled in their
mouth [__] landed on your dick yeah
how about blindfold sex that's the next
one blindfold is they're kind of mild
that's kind of you suck dick on accident
I close my eyes so I'm blindfolding
myself dude all I need to do is take my
contacts off and I can't see [__] yeah I
know what you mean sometimes I gotta put
my glasses on I like the idea that
blindfold sex which is oh we're gonna
make a sandwich
and then you stick your dick in
someone's mouth
not just me making out with the pillows
there's no surprise I know who it is
unless they do a switch on me
surprise and then I'm like somebody's
sucking my dick but do you like do you
like that idea of like someone sucking
your dick and you'll never know who it
was you'll never know if it was a guy or
girl or a [__] dog no because
if it was good if it was really good it
would eat me apart because I wouldn't I
wouldn't want it again you know what I
would do because I'd be like oh I don't
care if it was Santa Claus I need it
again I'll tell you what I would do I
would have Hannah come in and suck
blindfolded Joe's dick but
I would play hella dog noises
because that would make is it like when
they prank kids and then they have them
blindfolded they put it like in a
[__] orange and then they replace it
with a dog's ass oh yeah they think of
they stick their finger in a dog's ass
they're like they're Halloween spaghetti
things
[Laughter]
I like comparing that with such innocent
examples all right
do you think you could stay hard if you
heard of that sloppy [__] dog noises
I'd [__] buy a dog the next day I
mean hear the caller jingling around
and then you hear like you hear a bowl
of water
your cat opener with a better picture
wet dog food just just eating
enough listen
well sounds like a dog that's too many
sounds
good but I think I was getting blown by
a [__] Rottweiler but you'll never
know I think I'm gonna be out of the
zone
I might leave Hannah for a dog
that's the right answer and then Hannah
With Tears In Her Eyes it was mean the
dog's the new assistant manager at June
don't get the job
pretty good okay obviously cuckolding
okay we've heard of that everyone knows
about it feels like it's kind of on the
rise huh I think we should try it out it
feels like something people get accused
oh I can't pay my rent please [__] my
wife
precisely what about claustrophobia
having sex in public
um is like the opposite right but
claustrophobia is like you're like
having sex like a [__] AirPort
Extreme privates like people who are a
claustrophobic are stressed so you're
stressed of having sex okay you're
hyperventilating yeah yeah having sex in
a coffin or something I like being
comfortable too I don't want to be all
squished yeah I want to become
uncomfortable dude even [__] in my
old Ford Escort I was like this is not
comfortable dude I did something pretty
similar to this what'd you do I was
playing hide and seek and I ended up
hiding in the same spot as a girl I
liked
where were you guys behind a curtain it
was like one of the closets and oh God
damn it how did you know
it was a little closet you did it close
the closet one of my closets where oh
wait one of your students to live yeah
you you uh uh you're playing hide and
seek as an as an adult
[Laughter]
but I [__] like a kid
I don't know how to put it in where does
it go am I doing it right do you feel
anything it's funny because oh my dick's
still little when he said I played hide
and seek like that's something I would
totally imagine Quest Crew to do when
they get together
them doing [__] like that that's funny
you say that because that's exactly who
is playing oh [__] were you there how
about gagging what's your guys thoughts
on gagging
I mean I don't want to be on the verge
and throw it up
you're just watching her you're going
how could you put that in your Oh
I thought it was like you're about to
throw up oh God hear my wife
it seemed hot for a month but then like
I don't know yeah there's a 30-day
expiration it's like it's like porn
looks better than what it really is in
real life
really
a lot of it
the real life is
man you ever you ever met somebody who
thinks that they're being really [__]
deep but they say the most generic [__]
ever yeah
that would be that that's true me when I
hear myself talk let me let me just
point out the obvious but do it
profoundly
the real life is never this That Never
As Good it's really not I mean at least
your presentation isn't like those
people um
I like it I'll be honest though gagging
100 like it how do you know it's sincere
yeah
it's a charade dude
she's lying to me she knows you like it
she's not gonna not gag the sounds to
make you you guys really think so yeah
yeah
next one dude what else you got what
about gerontophilia what is that
believe it or not this is where people
are sexually attracted to elderly people
oh yeah like geriatric so it's not even
playing elderly it's like actual old guy
I'm not attracted to old people at all
at all at all I wish I was a little more
though I wish I wasn't I don't know more
options I guess
I think I would do well in that actually
I don't know no guarantees they gave up
one already you want to see a grandma
and get absolutely not oh but I just
said you know maybe maybe that opened up
more doors for me or something don't you
think why do you need more doors open
yeah just gotta try it out just gotta
try new things what about humiliation
Nick you like humiliation oh yeah dude I
like that I like to be humiliated it's
kind of my thing it's like Anthony we
know Anthony does because he likes to
the CEO [__] yeah he has to be
financially dominated
Joe you like humiliation like if you
told your dirty little boy
uh nah I don't know
my feelings hurt during sex I want to
feel loved
so if you had somebody like having sex
with you and telling you that all your
crypto picks were [__]
who's never gonna hit ten dollars why am
I so hard
I like humiliation I love it your script
writing sucks
I'm so curious where the Kings come from
it comes from somewhere yeah yeah
but it's like really you bad you bad bad
how many of these like kinks are very
novel though right like I feel like
after you do some of these Kinks long
enough like maybe maybe like say six
months is there a point where you just
go let's just do the regular stuff
you know yeah a lot of it's from some
people have kinks they haven't even
tried yet and they just think they have
them and then someday they do it and
they go yeah I'm good I think that's why
I'm so boring with sex now because you
tried it all because I thought you saw
the world the porn was I thought that
was better and they're like oh look at
how much he looks like he enjoys the
anals and then you do the anals and
you're like yeah I like how you say look
at how much he enjoyed it
is that important
can you cut to the guy's face again I
like to see it as expressions
[Laughter]
back to the guy who's getting [__] cut
to his face that used to make me mad
right now I mean every single time in
porn right when they're about to bust
and then it's like he's getting ready to
come on her face yeah they always cut to
him going oh gonna come and I'm like I'm
about to come and I don't want to see
his face when I'm about to come we're
filmmakers we can kind of help you okay
so what is it wire what is it these
different different category no we're
definitely in this in this space
Colleen lionheart's in the space so we
she's a star the guy's not actually
about stars they cut to the guy's face
because the guy needed to beat it for a
little bit longer than they were waiting
for yeah but as a guy [__] I see it you
know what you know what this is though
it's like I see a beautiful
I'm preparing to also come yeah
in the middle of it they cut to a man's
face and he's going like
yeah and there's two things that happen
okay
now I gotta start all over again because
he ruined it the other one is I didn't
time it right I want to come when he
does but I end up coming on his face oh
no it's [__] funny dude
that's the no win scenario and I get mad
because I'm like yeah that's not what I
wanted that's white supremacy man yeah
dude that's probably why it's surprised
that is so white sometimes you just take
your owls and go you know at least we
both had a good time I was gay last
night yeah all right I tried it once
yeah the gay thing I came on a guy's
face on my computer screen I know what
are you gonna do it happens you can't
win all the time that's why they have
microfiber cloths yeah I don't like that
that's not why I don't like that that's
why God made microfiber cloths yeah
that's where the Shamwell came from
that's why now I fast forward to the
come scene to make sure it's not but it
does kind of kill the the movie for me
yeah yeah spoiler alert you know like
that's not good yeah we're gonna think
about pregnancy fetishism
I don't
foreign
by the way is there anything more
beautiful than the female formula [__]
no she looks no how cool am I that
sounds like a terrible but beautiful
name
The View audience would be going insane
right now but you guys are too close
that's not more arousing for a guy
that's had like a a baby already is it
like with his wife maybe it is for some
I think that's even biologically [__]
up because it's true
she's already taken she's already got a
baby going on why are you trying to come
on her did you and Judo do it when she
was pregnant not that much but we still
did it but yeah it was better when she
wasn't pregnant right did you close your
eyes
come up to the question
Bart looks like he went to war bro parts
are getting flashbacks of [__] [__]
and it's pretty cool just knock a girl
there's less options yeah it's like only
so many positions well like when the
people for her when when
they're pregnant when they're pregnant
and you do it
it's only based off of love oh you're
not in the [__] mode or the horn mode
this is good inteller you know it is
good Intel because it's more just like
you love each other and you guys are
getting into providing for when you guys
aren't in like not pregnant
then it could be in [__] mode or
whatever mode you know that's a good
mode to be in yeah yeah it's like sport
mode can whoever it can if you're gonna
edit this while Bart's snaring off
thinking about all that stuff just put a
bunch of Choppers and some like machine
could you if you could do black and
white yeah yeah that would really
helpful equation because when someone's
like
someone's like waddling go like this oh
is that heartburn that's not like the
sexiest
sure yeah TR
ick
foreign